- Hi, everyone.
Welcome and thank you
for joining me in this lightning session.
For the next 20 minutes,
we are going to explore
how you can turn siloed
enterprise system data
into AI-driven innovation.
My name is Angie Guemes,
and I am a senior specialist
in the industry solutions team at MongoDB.
What we do is that we
basically help organizations
maximize the value of their data
by providing industry specific solutions.
These are either to help them
tackle specific challenges
or improve customer experiences.
All right...
The agenda for today is the following:
First, we're gonna talk
about AI innovation
and its challenges, what it is,
we're gonna explore some vision of that
through a couple of demos.
And we are also gonna talk about
why are some of these AI initiatives
not getting to production.
Then we're gonna talk about
the operational data layer as a solution,
what it is and the layers that compose it.
And finally, we're gonna talk about
the benefits that you will get
from using MongoDB Atlas as
your operational data layer.
All right, so getting started,
these are some AI concepts
or capabilities that have
been broadly talked about,
especially the last couple of years,
and they are becoming
increasingly fundamental
across industries,
generating key areas of opportunities
for many use cases.
Let's explore them in a
little bit of more detail.
First, we have Gen AI.
This is what it's being allowing companies
to streamline and automate processes.
For example, based on
the picture of a product,
they can generate multilingual
descriptions of it,
but this descriptions match the tone
and essence of the brand.
AI-powered search is
allowing us to discover data
in a much smarter way,
searching through semantic meaning
rather than just keywords.
This is how companies are
able to match a customer
to a specific product
or an employee to a
specific insight instantly.
Then we have Retrieval-Augmented
Generation, or RAG.
This is very critical for
reducing hallucinations,
expanding LLM capabilities
through proprietary data as context,
critical for trusted and
grounded AI responses.
And well, last but not least,
agents and multi-agents:
These have added a new layer
of decision-making and reasoning.
They are able to act, not just answer,
so they are able
to streamline processes
and workflows end to end.
Ultimately, all of these have one goal
that is shared across them
and this is to improve
customer experiences
and/or enhance their
operational efficiency.
And there's also something
really exciting about all these
and is that we are already
seeing these happen
across different use cases
and customer success stories.
And just to provide a
little bit of more insight,
I'll go through the last two.
Nova Nordisk is a leading
healthcare company
and they are augmenting LLMs
with their own proprietary data
to make the generation of
clinical study reports faster.
It used to take them 12 weeks
to generate these reports
and now it only takes them 10 minutes
and only with a fraction of the resources
that it would take them in the past.
Thanks to this, they are able
to hit faster times to market
for new treatments,
and as part of these initiatives,
they are leveraging different
AWS technologies like Bedrock,
specifically they're
using Cloud III and Titan
and also MongoDB Atlas Vector search.
And then DevRev.
Dev, DevRev, sorry,
provides support chatbots for their teams,
for their internal teams,
and as part of these initiatives,
they are also using MongoDB Atlas on AWS
and other products like
AKS and VPC peering
for support and connectivity.
All right, so I brought
to you a couple of demos
to paint a more clear picture
of these AI initiatives.
With this first one,
we are going to explore
how you can take advantage
of fresh purchase data
to enhance the experience
of the customers.
So in this case, the user
is at the E-commerce store.
They will go to their cart,
proceed to check out...
Oops, sorry, I have this issue
at the AV testing, so lets...
The show must go on,
right? So second time.
The user will be at the eCommerce store
and here they will go to
their cart, place an order,
and this will trigger our invoice
and recommendation microservice.
So when the user clicks on See Details,
they will be given a popup with
their digital receipt here,
encompassing relevant order transaction
and loyalty information.
And if they scroll down from the receipt,
they will be able to see
a list of recommendations
with products that they might also like
based on the items
purchased in this order.
And like that, every
single digital receipt
will contain a unique and
relevant set of suggestions
leading to a more engaging
shopping experience.
Customers can also
download the PDF version
at any point in time
and leverage this for their finances.
Ultimately, if a customer makes a purchase
at a store physically,
they expect to see that same
history inside their account
so that if they then
go to the landing page,
we are able to leverage that data as well.
So this is how we can instantly
activate fresh purchase data
to continue the shopping
experience beyond the checkout,
and also leveraging that same
data to further personalize,
for example, the landing
page, in this case.
Awesome.
In this next example,
this is a financial
portfolio management system
that continuously scans
the market for insights.
At the top we have
performance and asset graphs,
and at the bottom...
Oh, and the graphs are related
to the manager's portfolio.
At the bottom we have a table
of diversified portfolio of ETFs.
Each of these contain
a different indicator,
for example, sensitivity around VIX, GDP,
interest, unemployment rates,
and also sentiment scores.
All of these are calculated by
three, daily scheduled agents
that continuously scan
the market for insights.
Additionally, agents can also interact
with the agents (laughs)
through this AI assistant
so they can ask natural language questions
and get insights from the
latest data in the market
and plan their risk aware strategies.
Agents have already done
all these heavy lifting
of constantly scanning
through different unstructured
and semi-structured sources,
such as, financial analysis,
financial news, and also social media.
So portfolio managers can rest assured
that they are actually interacting
and getting the latest
data from the market,
and they can use that extra time
to leverage their plans,
instead of having to making
this discovery themselves
while still retaining the full
control of their operations.
They can also see which
tools were utilized
to generate the responses
for each of the questions.
So, all of this looks
pretty amazing, right?
We all wanna have something like this.
However, I hate to break it to you,
that many of these AI
initiatives are failing today.
They are either being abandoned
or they fail to meet their objectives.
So let's understand, why is this?
Why are some of these AI initiatives
not being able to get to production?
Well, the first reason is the misalignment
with the organization's strategic goals.
When you start planning about
designing AI initiatives,
this should be able to create
tangible business value,
enhance the operational efficiency,
and create a sustained
competitive advantage.
Another example or reason,
and the one I would like
to focus the most during this session,
is incomplete and fragmented data.
When you start building
your AI initiatives
without first making a pause,
taking a look at your data layer,
at your foundational data layer,
well, you will start
fitting your initiatives
with data that has poor quality,
data that is insufficient or incomplete,
or because still many data
is scattered across
different legacy systems,
well, it becomes very hard
to integrate or activate.
If you take that combo
and you pass it to a large language model,
you will get inaccurate outcomes,
hallucinations and bad
business consequences,
missed opportunities, bad user experience,
and the worst, damaging your reputation.
We know how hard it can be to
build a strong loyalty base,
and here's a little data,
more than 60% of customers
will change the brands
after a single bad user experience.
So that is something we want to avoid.
So how can we guarantee complete, accurate
and real-time data?
Well, let me introduce to you
the Operational Data layer, or ODL.
This is an architectural
blueprint or approach,
which job is to consolidate
siloed enterprise data
into a single, reliable data layer.
Let me walk you through
the five layers of an audio, ODL, sorry,
that will guide a robust implementation
using MongoDB Atlas as
your core data layer.
First, we have the source
systems or systems of record.
This is where the actual
data gets originated,
and as you can see from the examples,
many of these systems
were built with a single use
case in mind at the time,
so as a result their
schema does not longer
accommodate the modern day applications.
An example of this, or a result of this,
that you will struggle to see
a complete view of an entity.
For example, a retailer that struggles
to have a complete view of users
throughout their shopping journey,
because operational
sales are in one system,
returns and refunds are
in a different system,
their loyalty or preferences
in another system, and so on.
Data from the source systems,
is then ingested into the ODL layer
through different mechanisms,
including ETL, Change Data Capture,
and here you can also leverage
MongoDB Atlas Stream Processing
for handling large stream process of data.
I think it's a good time
to make a pause here
and mention that if
you're interested about
any of the products I will be
mentioning during the session,
we have a booth right here
behind us at the Number 822
and we have many experts on site
and actually we brought the demo
so you can test them yourself
if you're interested.
All right, the third
layer is the actual ODL.
Here it's represented by MongoDB Atlas
and it's where we consolidate
structured, unstructured,
and semi-structured data
into a single flexible document.
Then we have the processing layer.
This layer is in charge
of making the data from the ODL available
to the applications.
This layer right here is
very critical for security.
It enforces governance through encryption,
access control, policy-based
filtering, et cetera.
And the last but not least,
and I think we can all
guess what layer is next,
are the actual applications.
So these applications
can include operational
and system apps.
They can include business
intelligence tools.
They can include, of course,
the next generation applications
with Gen AI and agents.
All right, so what are some
key enablers that you will get
from using MongoDB Atlas as your ODL?
I really like this diagram
because it encompasses the main benefit.
All of these building
blocks that you see here
would usually come from
single-purpose systems.
For example, smart search or embeddings,
and globally the flexible schema.
And here they are all natively integrated,
living with your data.
So, actually we're actively working
to integrate Voyage AI
embedding models and rerankers
to make this process even more seamless.
So this is the biggest benefit
we bring to development teams: simplicity.
We are reducing the complexity
of their operational overhead
by having all the data and capabilities
in one single trusted,
reliable data layer.
Some of the key enablers
that you will get from this:
Our first, the unparalleled simplicity
from the flexible document model.
You can store different
complex data types,
such as vectors, such as graphs,
the AI embeddings.
And in this example,
we have operational data
living alongside AI.
This is what it allows us to
query for relevant products
in the digital receipt demo
without having to move
data outside of our system.
Then we have agents' memory capabilities.
Memory is a key capability for agents,
allowing them to store context
throughout interactions,
learn from past interactions,
and ultimately get better at their tasks.
You can leverage Atlas as
your agent's memory layer.
Another thing that you would get from this
are the powerful queries.
We have full text search,
semantic search, hybrid search,
all natively integrated.
You can also have other
powerful search queries,
such as geospatial queries,
and they're all within the same workflow.
So this makes operational
overhead even less
and allowing more simplicity
for your teams to develop faster,
focus more on innovation,
rather than just seeing what
technologies to integrate
to make all this happen.
And here is an example
of SvectorSearch query
that we are executing.
I took it from the digital
receipt demo as well.
Another thing, and the one
I really like the most,
is removing friction.
When you build AI, you really
need to start integrating
with data from different systems,
and you can integrate different frameworks
for developing AI.
Atlas reduced friction
with many, many of these.
This is one example,
where we are leveraging,
this is the financial demo
that I showed you earlier.
We are using Amazon Bedrock
to expand capabilities
and have better responses.
We are also initializing the memory layer
using MongoDB Atlas,
and then we are using LangGraph
as an orchestrated of these...
orchestrator, sorry, of these agents.
And you can see it's just as
simple as passing all this
to the initializing function.
And we are leveraging, again,
Atlas as the memory layer for the agents.
Another example of ease of integration
with object storage, for
example, is this one.
In our digital receipt demo,
when the user first downloads
their digital receipt,
we will generate it and store
it in Amazon S3 buckets.
That URL is then gonna be
embedded into the document
as metadata inside the file_url field.
For subsequent downloading times,
we just pull from that same URL.
And well, last but not least,
we have the enterprise ready factor.
So, we run in over 30 plus AWS regions.
We also have
many audits at security
level, for example,
we are able to encrypt your data
and having it secure, not
only at rest and in transit,
but also during use.
So ultimately if you have
everything in one place,
it is easier to secure,
easier to maintain,
and easier to onboard new team members.
So as we wrap up, here are
some of the key takeaways
that I would like you to
take from today's session.
The first one is to keep innovating
and using all these
trends and frameworks
and technologies that come
from the AI innovation wave,
but doing so without losing the focus
on what business value it brings to you.
And then last but not least, also,
AI is just one
of the many waves of
innovation that are to come.
We don't know what's gonna be next
in the next 15, 20 plus years,
but what it is a fact,
is that if you invest in the
right data foundation today,
you are going to be much better equipped
to develop whatever comes tomorrow.
All right, so I really hope
that you had enjoyed today's session,
that you had learned something new.
If you can please take a moment
to also evaluate the
session through the app,
I would, thank you,
and keep enjoying this amazing
experience of AWS re:Invent.
Thank you.